[Music]
hi i'm sabine from geek culture in
singapore how are you simone i'm very
well very well how you doing
i'm doing good thanks for asking um i
know that fans have been waiting for
this movie for the longest time
did you feel pressured in any way when
you were making this movie
well i i felt i i understood and was
aware of the the expectation and the
pressure
i didn't necessarily
i just sort of i felt it and then wanted
to make sure that we
respected the material
and i knew it was a
a fan base that deserved the most
elevated version of of mortal kombat as
we could we could muster so
um i was very aware of of the and you
know the excitement out there and that
just sort of made it all the more
exciting for us as we'll make it
yeah i think you mentioned that you know
that
this movie
has a very strong fan base it has such a
rich history it's got comics it's got
games it's got like numerous new
adaptations as well um what are some
elements from the canon that you used in
your movie
well there's a lot i mean
so i i think to probably to answer that
question is
what what
what we did and what i was looking for
in the mortal kombat canon and the dna
of model combat i really did uh
and studied and analyzed and looked at
what were the key ingredients
within mortal kombat
and
broke that that down and made sure that
we weren't changing those fundamentals
and really it was about elevating those
fundamentals into a very cinematic big
epic
version of this
and so
it was obviously the characters of the
absolute core and essence of of the
mortal kombat franchise
and that's why people love it i think my
my feeling is people love it because the
characters are so so much loved and
therefore and then you add the tonality
of the comedy and then there's this
very serious
side to it which talks about the the
rules and the law and the all of the
detail and the rich history of each
character and how they interweave
and then there's the brutality of it and
then there's and so what i wanted to do
was take all those elements and those
ingredients and
make a really beautiful cinematic
experience
because i felt that actually the
those elements can coexist in a really
i wanted to make it feel crafted and
elevated
and and give it the
sort of respect and care that i i felt
it deserved and the fans deserve so
that was the approach
thank you so much i think any friend
hearing that would be so pleased
um just to add on to my previous
question i know
did you
did you put in anything that was your
own element or make any changes that
kind of make this movie
your own if that makes any sense
yeah it makes total sense
i think it's a stylistic thing rather
than a content thing
yeah so i didn't feel like
i wanted to there are some things that
we changed a bit
but
we really didn't want to
change those fundamentals so
stylistically
i felt that my job was to create this
tone feeling and essence that that moved
those key ingredients into into a
[Music]
very visually powerful
fun
entertainment experience but it but i
wanted it to feel loved and cared for on
the characters and and
the other thing that was really
important to me and what i tried to
bring to it was
to to bring
some really
powerful raw emotion
to
to moments and scenes and characters so
you feel for
these characters even though they're
very unreal but there's a certain
connection you have with these
characters
i thought we could still achieve that
and that's really what i'm trying to
achieve and you know volcanoes being
really funny
there are times when you know
that they
that there's a really
really sad moments and really emotional
moments and
that's that emotional part of it was
very important
yeah i think you know the team and i we
actually saw the movie before this and
we absolutely loved it we loved it so
much
and you know we left the movie and we
were like you know what the ending kind
of hints at a sequel so i'm gonna ask
you point blank is there gonna be a
sequel
well interesting i didn't let anyone
talk about a sequel um
because
that was
it's not really for us to decide
it's for the fans to decide if there's
if this film if people like the film and
they like the direction we're going and
they like it and then
then
yeah of course we'll we would make one
no one's gonna say no
but it wasn't really for us to decide so
we didn't we don't really talk about the
sequel much we didn't
we really yeah we just didn't talk about
it all the studio were the same they're
you know these are the guys
that did shazam and it and they've all
got sequels but they never it's just in
their it's in their approach to to not
assume because once you start assuming
you're going to have one you make all
the wrong decisions
you know you get too
about it and it's like
so we i said to everyone look let's just
get this one do our best to get this as
right as we can
and then we'll see where we go and
so
um we'll see
okay take it from this fan so you get
from the same one
okay thank you so much simon that's all
the time i have with you but thank you
it's been a really lovely talk
my pleasure great to meet you
you